tout à côté il veut faire de plus en
plus de jeunes
bernard et ou pas il va pleuvoir mettre
des chemises en dut faire dieu grec elle
à 53 exact d'accord et ben vous les
faites pas du tout je ne dis pas non
mais vous êtes très beau très bien
conservés que jeune d'esprit en tout cas
cette jeune d'esprit
allez-y dit une phrase un peu john soir
pour voir si vous êtes jeunes allez-y
week est à grove asie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on lance tout de suite le hashtag grosse
tristesse et dites nous si vous aussi
vous avez vécu des moments de solitude
comme ça des moments de deux tristes et
aux gamins à la radio le soin et tous
nos gens ce mode du coup un vernissage
lego lego c'est à dire en fait une autre
ag qu'à loger quelques retours wave asie
écoute de rouleaux ou tu vas voir c'est
de la balle à coups de rouleau s'est
déroulé il ya plusieurs façons
différentes y paraît d'accord les ai dit
moi par john soit hier soir je suis
allée une soirée c'était vraiment génial
on s'est vraiment beaucoup amusé why
hier soir une soirée de ouf
y'avait reçoit y avait des petits qu on
a tout explosé sa mère
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]